this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description get their first two
months free deep in the mountains of
Austria lies the small but scenic town
of hallstatt but this isn't that it's an
exact replica built 9,000 kilometers
away near Hong Kong Austria China it's
home to European architecture Chinese
cuisine and all the traffic of North
Korea because during the day it may be
the wedding photo capital of the region
but after the Sun sets its cottages
become remarkably quiet
China's look-alike towns of places like
Paris Berlin London and Jackson Hole
Wyoming aren't alone in many places
across China there are far more houses
than there are people long rows of
apartments even entire cities set
completely or mostly empty in total
approximately 50 million units or 22
percent of China's entire urban housing
but this doesn't mean they aren't being
bought because they are like crazy ten
years ago most people were as you'd
expect buying homes for the first time
today it looks like this second homes
are the majority and people are buying
almost as many third homes as first
these aren't cheap either in Los Angeles
the price per square foot is six hundred
and thirty three dollars in Shenzhen 805
and close your eyes because you don't
even want to know the price in Hong Kong
now consider the difference in wages the
average annual income in Shenzhen is
around seven thousand five hundred US
dollars compared to sixty thousand in LA
something clearly doesn't add up people
in China are buying homes like Americans
buy cars but they're leaving them empty
and it's not clear where the money is
coming from or why they're being built
the usual explanation is that China's
government is so desperate for economic
growth that it
old bridges to nowhere and houses to
look at but that's only one part of a
much bigger story China's troubles begin
with its political system the central
government is the highest level of its
only party here laws are written and the
fate of the nation decided Beijing is
the ultimate authority it appoints
everyone from secretaries to governors
and isn't afraid to move them around
should any one official gain too much
influence but it would also be a mistake
to see China as one singular power
because below the central government is
a network of local divisions 22 regional
provinces for municipalities for
autonomous regions and two special
administrative under those are over 300
Prefecture --zz followed by the less
important counties townships and
villages
now just as Californians have different
concerns than do Texans or Floridians
China is a big country and the interests
of a coastal exporter like Shenzhen are
very different than those of say a more
independent region like Inner Mongolia
the same is true for different levels of
government while Beijing writes the
rules cities apply and enforce them
often very differently and there's one
awkward little detail cities receive
just 40% of tax revenue but are
responsible for 80% of their expenses so
naturally they need another source of
income and this is where things get
interesting in China rural land is
collectively owned everyone and also no
one owns it which means it can't be the
location of a new luxury apartment but
luckily for cities they have the power
to rezone land from rural to urban which
can be developed in other words they own
a money printing machine watch this
first a city buys cheap rural land which
it then redefines as
urban and finally sells to developers
and it's now much higher price like
magic over and over and over again
cities get much needed cash and
developers built housing like it's
nobody's business now unlike states in
America local governments here are
generally forbidden from taking loans
but again there's a loophole cities can
create a local government financial
vehicle which is a fancy way of saying a
state-owned company and by giving it
that new urban land the company can do
what the city legally can't borrow money
which they can use to build roads
schools and on occasion replicas
Austrian towns this is so effective that
in some years land sales account for 40
percent of local government revenue plus
all this construction increases GDP
which just so happens to be the way
officials get promoted it's a perfect
system at least until it's not if or
when housing prices fall so does city
revenue and all those loans probably
won't magically disappear Beijing wants
to avoid a housing crisis but cities
just want to survive and governors get
promoted which puts the two at odds
eventually cities start running out of
land to sell and have no choice but to
build more like this one which spent two
billion dollars blowing up the tops of
mountains those developers who purchase
that land by the way are required to use
it which leads to many often quickly
constructed low-quality houses and that
brings us to the second question why are
people buying them and doing it like
their life depended on it well for one
because it kinda does thanks to the
famous one-child policy
China now has the entire population of
Canada more
men than women and that means fierce
competition for marriage men are
expected to own at least one property
before even being considered it's one of
the most important elements of social
status for many real estate isn't just
an opportunity it's a downright social
necessity because of this friends and
family pull money together to help buy
homes for their children and that's how
nearly everyone in a country with the
per-capita GDP of the Dominican Republic
can afford some of the most expensive
homes on the planet the other big factor
is that Chinese citizens save like crazy
when it comes to saving money there's
China and then there's basically
everyone else where Europeans put 4% of
their disposable income in the piggy
bank
Chinese drop nearly 40 the problem is
where can they put it China's domestic
stock market is just too risky
and its banks are often seen as
unpredictable which makes real-estate a
Chinese investors best friend it alone
accounts for 70% of all household wealth
it also doesn't hurt that property tax
is a beautiful zero percent when taxes
are only paid upfront why wouldn't you
buy as soon as possible and just sit on
it put all this together and you have a
recipe for extreme house buying an
amazing 90 percent of homes are owned by
their residents Europe and the US stand
at 69 and 64 percent respectively and
while we're on the subject of crazy high
numbers 94% of Chinese Millennials who
don't already own plan on buying in the
next five years
what else do 94 percent of people agree
on not even China can quench this thirst
for real estate despite laws against it
billions of dollars flow out of the
country every year into foreign property
it's so common in places like Vancouver
that earlier this year it introduced a
20% tax for
foreigners the irony is that while
cities like Beijing and Hong Kong have
so little room people are forced to
sleep underground these 50 million homes
can't find renters so hey if you live in
California I think I may have found an
escape plan anyway not only are these
homes bought without interiors literally
just concrete walls but they're also
usually located outside city centers
where there aren't as many jobs now the
assumption in all of this is that
eventually people will come and
speculation will become reality the
eastern side of Shanghai for example was
once laughed at by Milton Friedman for
being totally empty today as a financial
capital of the world with a GDP of 400
billion we can pretty safely say it's
proven the haters wrong China is in the
process of migrating 300 million people
from country to city and of course
they'll need a place to live inevitably
many of these cities will spring to life
that doesn't mean everything is peachy a
few things are decidedly not peachy
first remember that the vast majority of
empty homes is expensive commodity
housing these are not the kinds of
places you buy coming from a farm in the
country and second all these homes have
an expiration date in China a building
can be owned but the land beneath it can
only ever be leased from the government
for 70 years after that it's anyone's
guess whether ownership will be renewed
and if so for how much but the truth is
70 years is pretty optimistic think
about it this way if construction is
good for GDP why build once when you can
build and rebuild every few years it's
kinda like the iPhone if you'd like to
upgrade every year Apple will happily
sell you a new phone it's certainly not
judging except in the case of China's
housing developers are incentivized to
make short-term bets they know their
homes will only last a few decades
anyway which means using lower quality
materials meanwhile cities continue
taking loans and housing prices continue
rising unsustainably of course Beijing
knows all this it's aware of the bubble
the risks involved and it knows more or
less how to fix it
some combination of slowing down lending
reining in local governments and
introducing a property tax like Shanghai
the problem is real estate is so
intertwined with its GDP that any of
these solutions would seriously risk
slowing down its economy in the coming
decades the world will watch as China
does its best to carefully balance its
enormous challenges with its relentless
desire to grow its economy and realize
the Chinese dream as Beijing prepares
for economic change by diversifying its
revenue you and I should do the same
today's sponsor Skillshare helps you
learn new things so you can do just that
if you're still watching this it's clear
that hey you like learning things and be
you learn visually which means skill
shares video lessons are perfect for you
there are classes on starting your own
business taught by successful
entrepreneurs topics like how to start
programming your own apps and games from
scratch and creative classes like
drawing or my course on how to make your
own YouTube videos where I go over my
process from writing scripts to
animating them here's the thing there's
absolutely no risk so if any of this
sounds interesting
just give it a try because the first 500
people to use the link in the
description that get two months
completely free thanks to skill share
for sponsoring this video and to you for
listening